what's going on there reject nation
we're gonna watch nips nine of all of us
are dead if you're here bite your teeth
into that like button also thanks to the
boys at prepper for helping us edit down
these highlights and last but not least
full length watch as long as you sync up
with the time code for all of us or that
are at our patreon page special thanks
to all become super rejects let's watch
this
[Music]
[Music]
guys getting up on him i mean you go in
there
come on
finish him
keep going
somebody stab him
oh jeez
oh
gnarly effect
no
now's the time pres
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah
the wire work on this yeah
what is up with her eye
oh
i hope every episode they throw him off
a taller building man you kids just keep
surviving
oh oh jeez
god i didn't kill this guy yeah cut his
head like all the way off
and then put it in a box and drop it in
the ocean screw you man
[Applause]
ah
dude this guy's going to get loose
chenisharon by restraining
but we don't like taking our helicopters
to schools
yeah what are kids gonna do for us in
the apocalypse
oh thank christ
and only the laptop yeah
i'm sure
oh
no no
or someone else
he's not gonna understand that she means
literally
it's like an army hammer siege
i'm
she protected you guys yeah she's your
only chance if he comes back
helicopter
please try to wave them down and then
they just shoot them all like it's not
the living dead
are they just going to ignore them i'm
just going to walk right past they're
not saying anything
temperature be okay
[Music]
[Music]
rescue them after completing our mission
so they're going to die in there
they're definitely going to die in there
you're all going to die down here
oh the archer girl and stuff yeah
they're in the gym
it'd be so cool to be one of these guys
living at your call of duty zombies
fantasy
might as well just take care of them
don't tell me he just went into the
science lab
just so cool to be one of those guys
shoot a bunch of dead high school kids
he ultimate catharsis
just grab the only laptop in there and
run
oh damn
oh oh no
[ __ ] this situation's gonna cause us to
not take them huh yeah
i'm really curious about that
[Music]
[Laughter]
except for the whole flesh eating things
yep damn it i had a feeling i had a
feeling damn it
just quarantine them when they're there
like the original craziest
what a crock oh [ __ ]
wow
no
no
i know
oh
man
[Music]
foreign
can't you check to see if they've been
bit or something
yeah
man that sucks balls
how about you drop a few rations down
there it's the least you could do
okay
and i'm gonna have to worry with you
about not shooting the kids
he will be written up i'm going back
there to shoot them
first she starts the fire which opens
the door and then now she just she
couldn't wait to eat come away like 10
more minutes
is the cameraman slowly zooming in
can we get this tape out to as many
people
leon s kennedy over here
dude hijack that truck
or one of the many cars
you gotta know how to hot wire
what the [ __ ] is happening now
now's not the time to lose your mind
[Music]
oh
damn that looks like carbon steaming
you know it's true man
what's up
[Laughter]
oh
yep
[Laughter]
oh you guys can get sick though man it's
acid rain
[Laughter]
[Music]
ah
since it's a merciless situation man
everyone needs a catharsis
on the other roof stands peter parker
watching a video of jay jonah james
[Laughter]
about to have the best pep talk of his
life
lasts a while man
oh but your dad's on his way
to
you can do this
so you can't do that like walking dead
[ __ ]
the blood and the guts and all that
seems like you'd have enough
opportunities to try with all these
bodies around
[Music]
shh too loud too loud
wow that was a quick decision
your legs are not working today they got
to learn how to kill some of these man
[ __ ]
[Music]
no
no no no dude your mom
don't get in touch with reality
[Music]
oh no
how many cliffhangers are gonna be of
this guy about to die
[Laughter]
until the very last episode where they
finally just rip his body entirely apart
limb from limb and the goriest set piece
of the entire show who texted chainsaw
masquerade yes out today
there's nothing but good things about
hey i've heard if you don't expect much
it's fun
i'm excited i want to see it do a
reaction cut it up into eight parts is
it just one movie
it's a movie yeah
is it terrible
i wasn't kidding i mean i've heard that
it's not like amazing but if you want
leather face and you know gore gags and
icky texas atmosphere it's pretty
enjoyable
seems to be the consensus it's not great
but it's pretty enjoyable for texas
chainsaw you know i hate that franchise
i
know you do
that's exactly why you should rage watch
it i hate the franchise progressively
gets worse it's a mean ugly franchise so
repetitive that franchise it's a little
repetitive
a little
a little little tiny bit
the original sequels get very very wild
and wacky and then when they remade it
every one of them is just
okay we're gonna go with the edgiest
most icky looking tone we can and they'd
evolve into the same movie every time
and then every single one is the true
sequel to the arrangement
oh but that's the one the new one does
have is the original girl's back and
she's old now and she wants to kill
leatherface cause that's what we do now
i've been waiting for this day seems
like it found out well for dead it's
gonna be so good
just getting progressively more hopeless
by the hour
all of us have no hope all of us are
dead
on the inside
before we die on the outside
tired
of hiding out from zombies
oh [ __ ] they must be so hungry yeah
they're not thirsty anymore though
[ __ ] superman
[Laughter]
oh my god watch it this is like oh man i
have like the biggest headache gotta be
so short with everyone
guys just stop
stop talking i'm going on my own i'm
going yeah
you guys want to follow me up the
mountain you follow me i'm handling
business let's get out of the way
i got no time for your sentimentality
jeez man that helicopter moment this is
i just it was just so obvious from the
beginning like
they're looking they're not gonna
they're not gonna go with them salvation
is too yeah they're not gonna be too
close to be real i was like after
[ __ ] from the last episode
which of course you know you complain
about something
get a gazillion comments of people being
like
actually well here's why it's fine
so
thanks guys uh for all the information
uh it is taken into consideration and i
haven't forgotten it now you can like it
properly yeah you're supposed to nothing
is wrong with anything so no better just
so this episode
um yeah at the very top i'm like
nah the second they show up you could
just tell they ain't leaving with them
they ain't leaving nope no i can't fool
me okay they're banging them up and then
oh they got the laptop okay rescue them
all right
second one g bit that guy they showed
that it was like
that they're gonna
correlate it to
high school student that was a high
school student yeah all high schools
consistently carriers asymptomatic
quarantined them all right and we didn't
even get to watch uh what what chu su or
whatever his name was the coward guy we
didn't even get to watch him die first
hand he doesn't deserve extreme time
that's fair
the character the actor is a horrible
human being in real life yeah if you see
another smackdown smack him hit him in
the balls
he
deserves gosh
you think you'd be smart enough to not
do it so like you were doing that like
right in public
yeah i'm curious as to what her end game
is especially now that she's in the
lock-up like i'm i'm a human you got the
wrong gal what's going on stop like you
seem like you wanted the world to burn
just a second ago
uh she wanted the school to burn she
wanted a fresh start at life
she that's how she left she left on like
an optimistic like oh i'm gonna get on
my bicycle and there's more to look
forward to i started fresh burned the
past let the past die
and maybe and then maybe what she got
buried if you have to burn it if you
haven't uh
but maybe maybe yeah maybe she says that
thing about oh you know like when i'm
hungry i just burp i like have these
outbursts like i can't control myself so
maybe it's that maybe she couldn't
control her urge to bite him
that was enough to lure him over there
for a little while it certainly seemed
as though that could have been avoided
if she had this new lease on life and
didn't necessarily want to be locked up
for poking prodding experiments and
otherwise maybe she might not have
wanted to do that in the most obvious
place possible well it seems like the
okay so apparently the virus can hide
itself yes within the blood
so it comes and goes yeah oh that sucks
yeah milk they do live the military no
choice but to just assume everyone's
infected
i mean i get it see that it doesn't
bother me as much
like
what happened in the last episode
that all you guys defended yeah
of the helicopter and then not checking
to see like okay fine
um
that doesn't bother me as much
that what happened here because it makes
sense to me why they would react that
way like
wait a minute i have people from that
district
they might present themselves as
asymptomatic we don't know we we just
had this person chilling in our
quarantine zone for a while and we had
no idea and they were a student from the
school that's ground zero for all it
makes sense it makes perfect sense you
know and they they literally have the
most important piece of information
which is that laptop
and i think the call made sense you know
like okay if something goes wrong that
helicopter crashes or one of you guys
gets taken down we lose the laptop so we
can't risk it
as frustrating as it was
as much of a bummer
that right there does not get me annoyed
at the show
but annoyed at the situation yeah
absolutely good distinction yeah makes
sense yeah what if i wanted to look if i
i get it
um
but
yeah like sometimes that main general
guy just
it's a flip-flop between like oh you're
actually like an understanding guy dude
a human kind of a dick you're just kind
of like bottom line if they argue with
you shoot them yeah dude kill them why
aren't you killing them start killing
them i'm watching your feet you're not
killing them
yeah they're like charging and giant
attacking they're just desperate kids
come on now
yeah i mean that was this episode was so
so uh
is i just
turbo oil yeah it was emotionally
intense the guinon fight had like
[ __ ] like wire work that was insane
yeah it was like a kung fu fight it was
like a peacemaker fight yeah and a lot
of like really
like painful looking wire work in the
sense that so much of it was like okay
i'm gonna grab you by the leg and you're
like parallel to the ground and throw
you over here
like yeah
props to these there's so many of these
stunts that look like they're done in
camera with the main actor like i know
some of them but there are certain
things where i'm like either you did a
head replacement and a seamless cut that
no one could see or these kids are
willing to take a beating for the show
because some of that was super bone
crunching and convincing like an
assembly lady
i thought i was just making a joke and
then i cut to the next scene like oh she
really was she's
gearing up for re-election every time
you think she's gonna be
truly
not to say that she has no quality as he
would be but like a truly benevolent
human being it's always something yeah
she's always some leverage
i don't know where they're going with
that there must be some like i feel like
the final episode is gonna show us like
it's all going to be aftermath
she's the new ruler
of the new i don't know there's a
quarantined state of korea a part of
korea it's all zombies yeah and she's
going to be the president of it she's
got to decide whether to nuke it while
chung-sun and all his friends are inside
yeah trying to steal 20 million dollars
from the vault
yeah you know going through time loops
and stuff
yeah
maybe there's aliens involved that too
yeah
you know ever it's everything it's
everything we watch so many zombie
things on this channel that's right
zombie rejects
uh yeah that'd be cool
yes yes yes it was crossed over that
would be good army of the all of us are
dead
so yeah they have
the firefighter soju
going out there yeah man
everyone's hallucinating because they're
all sleep deprived and hungry mm-hmm but
they uh
yeah everyone just had to make harsh
decisions i know that was a great scene
between him and the guy in the street
too i thought that was they they're good
at sprinkling in
when it's appropriate little vignettes
like that those very intense moral
quandary there
he could have i mean you can't just saw
through it
no
i i don't know why we maybe couldn't
have attempted it from the other side
but at the same time i mean hey you like
push your seat back
yeah you know all i had to do was
unbuckle the seat belt
no but i i like that
that like the body language of that
situation because you watch him like do
all the firefighter things of like what
do you do in just a regular situation
like okay he's assessing the door they
do that like one pan around shot of like
all the things he's noticing
but i like this episode this was a good
one
it's a really enjoyable one yeah we're
back on track yeah after that shitty
last
terrible episode worst episode of any
show awful god
i'm glad i don't hate the show any
longer now back to really loving it it's
perfect can do no wrong
numbers a secret weapon they got feeder
blood it's like having a vampire in your
team yeah they gotta go get like a blood
bank like a hook up at a blip hey yeah
everybody
we believe in you number one yeah
we'll just pick we'll draw straws every
few hours or who gets to feed you yes to
eat he does
i would say if i was living in this
world i would go maybe she needs some
blood let's
let's try this out yeah
which i guess that puking thing just
wasn't a thing i guess you just ate too
much of that one guy
oonji yeah
you've been really fixated on that
puking yeah i thought it was like a
thing where like yo she can't eat
regular humans or something like that
but i guess it was just as she ate too
much
i don't know i thought that was like a
significant thing of like oh the zombies
the hambys can't eat the same way
regular zombies do so maybe there'll be
a twist there but
i don't know it really stood out to me
and now i'm like oh i guess she can just
eat that guy at the camp
good old chulsu
good for her yeah man i hope they killed
me i hope they killed chulsu
oh yeah he's he's got to be dead he
probably shot him a thousand times on
the spot
at least kill that
before he eats us all
and guinna man he's all messed up
poor guy just keeps having a restart
restart
super cut of guinon moments
no
no
just yeah just rage quick we know
it's a good episode all right good
episode let's do this people let's do a
page
william jones
william
i fixated on your last name jones guess
what it means mother effer was already
well
it means
jones is a perigenemic surname
meaning jehovah
has favored
wow
wow
you
think
jehovah favors you
more than we favor you wow jehovah can't
get out yeah enter
john and greg reid jones
smile on you now
we
love you more than jehovah ever will
yeah we can actually come to your
doorstep forget your whole surname
of the family you know you know what i'm
trying to say wherever you got a last
name from
a cream game at a theme park
we
love you i love you more
they love their whole family more yeah
because you're one of our patrons you
care about us
jehovah ain't got nothing on me
that's right man you you are the the
most beloved out of anyone not only are
you loved like you know any of god's
child you're you're loved like john the
apostle like his best and most beloved
friend you love like how mark walborg
loves sam jones oh ted dude
so much
love there
so
i want you to know that
if
you're having trouble
having a baby with your wife i will
offer up my sperm
send you a vial
happy february and we'll talk soon
[Music]